Aaron is found guilty he's sentenced to
10 years in prison we have enough money
to incarcerate them but we don't have
enough money the Hispanic has found in
the country without legal documents but
we can't deport them we don't have
enough money because African American
lives don't matter and it's the left
it's not the right african-americans you
talk about the Bible you look at what
African Americans support God says do
not allow a man live with another man
yet all the Democrats support gay rights
and African Americans support gay rights
thanks al gonna let you go you've said a
lot there let's get a reaction from our
guest
ok so part of what we're dealing with
here deals with the disparate treatment
in the criminal justice system and I'll
take an example we have cliven Bundy who
basically is stealing federal dollars by
not paying for grazing on federal land
the feds eventually come to collect and
he has an armed group that fend off the
the federal officers cliven Bundy lives
to tell the tale then we have saiful and
El Castillo who is a black man up in
Minnesota who has pulled over because
the police officer thinks he has a broad
nose just like a robber that they're
looking for and he has a concealed
permit and he is gunned down in the car
that's the disparate treatment that
we're talking about so when black lives
matter and and and I want to say when
black lives matter talks about black
lives matter what they mean is that
black lives really do matter and as long
as we treat black lives as cannon fodder
as long as we treat it as disposable as
long as we treat it as irrelevant we
have not fully grown as a society you
actually begin the book in 1999 in an
episode in near
city that is very well known the the
killing of amadou diallo you refer to
events like that and other events as
kindling in Ling for what's going on
today tell us more yeah and so in that
event you know amadou diallo was a black
man who stepped out on his front porch
to go get something to eat after a long
day's work this is this is regular and
the four officers from the New York
Police Department pulled up in front of
him came out guns blazing and fired 41
bullets at him and he went down 19
bullets hit he was unarmed he had no
criminal record he had nothing but being
a black man in New York City at the time
when you have broken window policing
theory governing the way that the NYPD
worked which meant that you had hyper
policing in the black community right
after that killing Rudy Giuliani who was
mayor at the time was on Nightline and
Ted Koppel's talking with it and Rudy
said my policies are working New York is
a safer City and he had his flowcharts
and you know does it show crime going
down and everything and I'm thinking
your policies are working you have an
unarmed dead man on a porch hit nineteen
times with 41 bullets shot at him your
policies are working and that's when I
began to start thinking through the wave
that policies work in order to begin to
undermine african-americans access to
their civil rights began to the
germination of white rage came in that
moment and because that broken windows
theory of policing which has led to like
stop and frisk stop and frisk so at the
time 50% of New York's population were
made of blacks and Latinos they
accounted for 84% of all stops and all
stops but the handful of whites who were
stopped accounted for twice as many of
the drop illegal drugs and illegal
weapons so if this was really about law
enforcement
you and in fact turn your police force
to look where the illegal drugs and
illegal weapons were but instead this
was turned towards the black and Latino
community where the drugs and the
weapons were not and so that's what I
mean about the ways that these policies
work because what that did was it led to
a kind of hyper criminalization in those
communities it led to amadou diallo from
kathleen now Pompano Beach in South
Florida Democratic caller on with
Professor Carol Anderson author of white
rage good morning Kathleen good morning
listening and I just want to say we as
Hebrew Israelite need to teach our kids
what was black people 24 slavery you're
always talking about slavery on slavery
slavery what were we doing before
slavery what we doing on the west coast
of Africa what were we doing when our
answers ran out of Jerusalem into West
Africa okay what were we doing and like
the guys said we need to go by God's law
God gave me the Hebrew Israelites laws
we broke the laws we are under a curse
he sent us into slavery because I broke
the laws that we need to go back to God
laws into this I think we're losing
Kathleen but we do understand the point
how about a response okay so the
response is I mean it there's there are
I talk about slavery because that's
where the book starts but there are many
scholars who fully document what was
happening in West Africa so that's just
not the focus of this conversation but
one of the things that you do see
and and I don't want us to also think of
slavery's as like Oh God because in fact
the enslaved fought they fought for
their freedom they resisted they broke
their tools they put rocks in the bags
instead of cotton they ran away they
resisted they fought for their freedom
and I want to also deal with the kind of
we broke God's law and so we are cursed
if we really are looking at the Bible
everybody has broken God's law so that
would mean that everybody would be
cursed and it's late I mean so we really
need to be much more judicious and we
need to be much more humane about the
way that we think about religion and the
Bible and Doug from Monrovia California
is calling it now on the Republican line
hi Doug
I heard miss Anderson from mrs. Anderson
lecture mentioned Wisconsin the state
legislature I was giddy and voter
suppression laws and I have read that
they offered free state IDs for people
for the purpose of mourning and I
believe that actual voter suppression
was on the University of Pittsburgh when
a Trump Stan was absolutely destroyed
and that seems to me his reasoning is
more as a voter suppression and where
young people are here when they hear
comments that you're both being
suppressed your rights are being taken
away what they hear is you're a victim
and you learn nothing be nothing more
than a victim and they'll never realize
their full potential and that is a real
disservice and it's propaganda that's
all I wanted to say thank you Dad your
thoughts yeah it's only propaganda if
it's not true and so the in Wisconsin
for instance one of the things that
Governor Scott Walker did was to
decrease the hours of the Department of
Motor Vehicles in democratic areas
particularly in
the City of Milwaukee while increasing
the hours for the Department of Motor
Vehicles in Republican areas of the
state you see for instance in Texas
where the when they passed SB 2 which
was the voter suppression law in Texas
that the state legislature knew that in
in over 200 counties they had Department
of Motor Vehicles in an 80 some of those
counties and that it was going to some
people were going to have to drive up to
250 miles in order to get a
government-issued photo ID but since
they couldn't this and it's not like
they had to drive but somebody had to
drive them and so in the original bill 4
SB 2 was a provision that dealt with
reimbursing people who had to drive a
long distance to get a government-issued
photo ID and the Republican legislature
drew a line through that reimburse 'el
so that in fact what we have is a poll
tax and so when you have the state
systematically identifying various
people by race and by class that is not
victimization that is exactly what the
government is doing and when people need
to understand that that is what's going
on it doesn't make them a victim
it makes them understand that they need
to stand up and resist our guest is
Carol Anderson professor of
african-american studies at Emory
University in Atlanta and author of the
book white rage the unspoken truth of
our racial divide our guest was educated
at Miami University also got a PhD at
Ohio State University other books she
has written eyes off the prize the
United Nations and the african-american
struggle for human rights and bourgeois
radicals
the n-double-a-cp and the struggle for
colonial liberation you can watch other
events with our guests especially at the
Miami Book Fair that that she just
attended at our website go to book TV
dork and just type in the name Caroline
sent in that event should come up for
you you write about President Obama of
course and part of what you write is
Obama's centrist solutions in utter lack
of radicalism in the face of a
recalcitrant and obstructionist Congress
should have made him a hero to
traditional Republicans but just the
opposite happen you're right by the end
of his term the President had an eighty
five point seven percent disapproval
rating among the GOP tell us more and so
you know we hear the language of Obama
being a socialist for instance as the
reason why he is so vilified except when
you look at for instance the absolutely
demonic demonized Affordable Care Act
right with you know Obama care if it was
created by the Heritage Foundation and
then adopted by Mitt Romney in
Massachusetts it has private industry
private insurance companies in fact
providing the insurance it is a centrist
solution to deal with the fact that we
have millions as one of the leading
industrialized nations we have millions
who did not have health insurance and
could not get health insurance because
of pre-existing conditions for example
that did not so his his centrality did
not win him any favors the fact that he
really tried to to walk this fine line
did not do anything instead what you saw
immediately coming out were the kinds of
vilifications he's Muslim he's Muslim
he's Muslim
and that Muslim is part of the other
ring making him not American making him
foreign making him some kind of you know
as a you know Manchurian Candidate kind
of of deal and when you so when you're
looking at his policies and as I say he
he he took over when the nation was on
the precipice of a massive financial
abyss he helped write the course against
a congress that whose first line was
opposed everything that he does
everything that he wants we're going to
try to make him as Mitch McConnell said
a one-term president
and so when you have that kind of just
resistance in the face of that
resistance right now the unemployment
rate is less than 5% income has risen
building starts have begun corporate
profits have increased and the man is
hated in a way that when you remove all
other variables all you can come up with
his race his blackness his very
blackness created this kind of sense
that this domain of the White House the
pinnacle of power was now occupied by
someone who could provide who was like
as I said the kind of pin ultimate in
aspirations the pin ultimate in
achievement and how where you have
little black boys and little black girls
thinking oh I too could be President of
the United States that is terrifying and
this is why you see those levels of
policies coming up beginning with
massive voter suppression have about 15
minutes maybe a little bit more left
with our guest and Helen is on the line
from Morrow Georgia excuse me Democratic
caller hi Helen hi good morning good
morning a professor Anderson I will not
call you mrs. Anderson because I don't
even know whether you're married or not
and I want to give you that respect
thank you speaking of victims and
victimization as per that last caller I
think about the war on drugs as in the
90s against aware of African Americans
were targeted as criminals and demonized
compared to the over 1 billion dollars
the recent bill passed in 2016 by and
pushed by the Senate to help the victims
of the latest opioid epidemic in
a lot of states and a lot of the people
who are victims of these the opioid
epidemic are white this is being pushed
by the Senate they have approved it and
they're waiting for the funding I
believe but can you compare and contrast
the way that people who are addicted to
these opioids are not demonized and
criminalized the way that blacks were
during the 90s with the mythical quote
crack epidemic where all blacks were
demonized and criminalized thanks for
calling in
absolutely absolutely in and there was a
study done by Princeton professor Naomi
Murakawa where she looked at the
difference between how crack was
identified and discussed and the way
that method methamphetamines were and
what she found was that crack was
criminalized as were the people you know
so that blacks were seen as crackheads
and that they needed to be incarcerated
methamphetamine in the in the in the
discourse was seen as a public health
crisis and that and and because meth was
seen as a as a white drug that was
affecting poor whites in rural America
and it's the same thing that I believe
that we're seeing with the opioid crisis
right now one of the things that I
detail in white rage is that in 1982
when President Ronald Reagan first
started talking about the drug crisis in
the United States even before there was
a drug crisis in the United States what
he talked about was that you know we're
not going after drug traffickers what
we're going to do is we're going to set
up these treatment centers and so you
had a kind of treatment framework for
understanding a drug crisis but when the
crack epidemic hit in fact then you saw
him come out in 1984 I believe it was
with his speech on the war on drugs
we're in and you saw a wave of
legislation coming through that
criminalized crack and made disparate
sentencing where you needed to have 100
times more powder cocaine than you need
it for crack in order to get the same
sentence and so that's where we see that
kind of disparate understanding about
who really is a victim and we began to
see what that how race plays out in
terms of of the way that the society
looks at the issues here's a question by
Twitter from Patrick asks about the
media here the media have always been
complicit and racism in America via
misinformation and selective information
what do you think yes and and so I I
remember so for instance yes Dylan roof
the young white man who went into
Emanuel AME Church and gunned down nine
African Americans during Bible study was
never defined as a terrorist in the
media even though he wanted to start a
race war even though he had a list in
his car of other black churches where he
was planning to commit these commit
additional killings never a terrorist
but as a troubled youth as someone who
might have some mental illness so and
and you never saw a discussion about
what kind of people could raise him yet
in the killing of Tamir rice who was the
twelve-year-old boy up in Cleveland
where the police he was playing with a
toy gun in a park and the police rolled
up on him and he was shot within three
seconds when the video tape came out to
show that the police officers account
was highly inaccurate in fact they lie
what the media focused in on was that
there were like well what kind of child
would be playing with a toy gun in a
park what kind of parents does he have
and you started seeing these headlines
about Tamir Rice's parents that's that's
that kind of that's an example of the
kind of disparate framing that we get in
in the media Bryn calling from
Collinwood Tennessee independent caller
for Carol Anderson hi Brent while since
I've called c-span I called when you had
your 50th anniversary for the voting
rights bill anyhow
the question I had for the professor
professor Anderson was I know I've seen
her on c-span book TV she's heard
discussions about her book that she's
had on there I like to find out if you
could elaborate on lynching specifically
I know I've done some slight research
what little research that I've done that
actually lynching the term Lynch or
lynching actually comes from the
Revolutionary War
a colonial judge I think in Virginia
that last name of Lynch who proposed
this policy to be used against Royalists
you know to lynch loyalists and to take
their property and what I like to find
out is is that true and also are many of
the cities in this country that are
named like Lynchburg that where that
name comes from is that is that related
and also when brendlin let me let you go
because you brought up a couple of
points and we want to get some other
calls and so fair enough to brandy got a
couple coins points in but go ahead okay
I don't know whether the roots of
Lynchburg Virginia are in fact because
of lynching I have read where lynching
in fact does come from the the
colonialist in Virginia but one of the
things that has happened is that while
black people were property killing them
was not profitable
but once the civil war was over and you
had emancipation then part of what you
see is a wave of lynching that happens
in order to reign in this quest for
freedom that black people had and and
one of the things as I talked about in
white rage is that the the key point is
that it's the policy so it's not that
it's bad enough that the lynchings
happen but it's that they were
sanctioned by policy sanctioned by the
courts allowed the the the killers were
allowed to to do that with absolutely no
consequences which may then add
normative joys from Houston
Joyce welcome to the program you're
calling on the Republican line for Carol
Anderson either hi yes first let me say
that I I am almost eighty four-year-old
black senior citizen grandmother and
you're talking about voter suppression
and you know it should be insulting to
every black person that it's said that
we don't have it's like we don't have
sense enough to get a picture ID and and
the reason that we don't want picture
IDs is because of voter fraud I have
worked in voting for years I have
witnessed so much fraud I have reported
it and nothing was done about it so that
let me know that there were people in
high office that knew that this was
going on and you know you have to have a
voter I did I went to get a library card
and I have to have picture ID to get a
voter to get a library card but when it
comes to voting I can walk in there and
I can vote I don't have to have picture
ID and you know this thing about the Oh
evil white man is a problem the white
man is not our problem we are our
problem and one of our main problems is
to break up of that black family because
when that black father was the head of
that home the Daniel's house was not
sort of a young black man and I young
black women and that's what we need to
come to the realization that we are our
own worst enemy we kill more of each
other
than any other group we're not dealing
with that we are dealing with this of
white
falta is slavery slavery is not problems
the white man is not our problem we are
our problem and you notice every time
it's time for voting you're going to
come up with this race stuff and it's as
to how the Liberal Democrats keep us
under control is why anger and I emotion
and once we come to the realization
affair using us and we have been used
for I vote for 50 60 70 80 years and we
are still complaining about what we do
not have we I don't I didn't teach my
children to say with no victims I taught
my children that they were victorious
and long as we say well you can't get
this you can do that you are teaching
them that they are victims and that's
what we need to stop Joyce thank you for
calling we do understand the point yes
and so let me move through that a law
professor in California in fact looked
at voter ID voter fraud the kind of
voter fraud that the IDS are supposed to
stop he found I believe 34 cases out of
1 billion votes from 2000 to 2014 that
kind of voter fraud is not the issue the
kind of voter fraud that has just seized
these GOP legislators is not the issue
and in in for instance in Milwaukee not
in Wisconsin up until like March or
April of this year
they weren't even allowing military IDs
as acceptable government ID so it's a
type of ID that that's part of the shell
game that's being played and again I
mean this this this what the research is
very clear on for instance is that if
you have a white man with a felony
conviction and a college degree has a
better chance of getting a job than a
black man with no felony conviction and
a college degree and and when you're
doing those kinds of comparisons that's
telling you
something is at work this isn't about
victimization it's about knowing what
you're up against
and I got to deal with this piece too
one of the pieces that really came
through for me in working on white rage
was that black people are fighting for
education we're doing what we're
supposed to do and when we fight for
education these policies come up to
undermine them it's like when Virginia
shut down the public school system or
Prince Edward County we're voting the
fact that we actually voted I mean
really voted in 2008 and 2012 the
response has been a wave of massive
voter suppression laws that in fact were
designed to reduce that vote also in
terms of drug use black people use drugs
either less than or at equal amounts but
are arrested at ten times the amount we
need to understand how that works
because that's real in this society Anna
calling from Desoto Texas Democratic
caller this will be the last call for
this segment hi Anna hi miss Anderson
thank you so much for bringing forth
what a lot of the last caller from
Houston Texas whooping if people forget
we were Republicans and Eisenhower was
the last one that we really truly voted
for there is a holiday called June 19th
and June 10th here in Texas and a lot of
people who move in state don't know what
it means well we were the last ones in
parts of Arkansas and Louisiana to get
freedom slavery had been over two years
before we were ever freed and sometimes
we still have that mentality with us
education mr. Chavis before us I
graduated from a segregated school and I
look at school districts now some of for
minority children I got a better
education under
aggregated system where black teachers
told us what we needed to do that you'll
always be behind the eight ball so you
got a study harder you got a work harder
and that's what's still going on today
and the people who call in and talk
about the Bible and we are under curse
I'm not under curse and I will never
teach my children or grandchildren that
they and I have one great grinder that
they're under a curse Texas State
Supreme Court Judge Harriet Murphy
she was my government teacher she taught
us how that we needed to not think about
the presidency but about Congress and
the Senate and that's where we're losing
out and that's why you have these voter
suppression because these congressmen
and Senators who are not doing their
jobs are still in the office and another
thing when you talk about the media we
don't have every magazine anymore
and Essence magazine that talked about
mr. Johnson if you wanted to know
anything Emmett Till at 13 years old
when he was killed
brutalized mr. Johnson put it in every
magazine and jet we don't have that
we're talking about booty calls and all
of that now that's the problem
Anna thank you for not calling a couple
of distinct points there anything I want
to respond to yes I would I would one of
the things that happened with the brown
decision is that when the state's
finally finally after about a decade or
more a fighting Brown one of the first
things that they did was to fire the
black teachers and and because they were
like we will not have black teachers
teaching white children I mean and so
this again becomes part of the policies
that we're talking about that undermines
African Americans access moving forward
we've talked a lot about the problems
and all about history a lot of episodes
moving forward is there one thing this
country can do to create better
conditions for African Americans more
equality yes I think they're one of the
big things that needs to happen
or that whites need to talk to whites
about racism because it's one thing to
have a black person sitting up here
talking but usually it's it's like okay
here we go again right but one of the
things that we saw happening in this
election for instance where that you had
families divided some who were Trump
supporters some who weren't and one of
the things that we saw with a lot of
Trump supporters the data are really
clear or that issues of racism are
strongly embedded in an alliance with
Trump in support for Trump having that
conversation about what is the real
history of this of this nation that's
how we're going to begin to move forward
understanding the cost that racism has
placed on the United States in terms of
our democracy in terms of our economic
strength Carol Anderson is a professor
of African American Studies at Emory
University in Atlanta and author of this
book it's titled white rage the unspoken
truth of our racial divide thank you for
being on c-span again appreciate it
thank you so much we have about a half
hour left in this Wednesday edition of
the Washington journal when we come back
we'll do a segment of open phones you
can talk about any topic you'd like
anything that we've talked about at the
table today or any other public policy
issues here are the numbers Republicans
call 202 seven four eight eight thousand
one Democrats seven four eight eight
thousand and independence 202 seven four
eight eight thousand two we will be
right back and talk more to you
[Music]
this holiday weekend on c-span here are
some of our featured programs on
Saturday we'll take a look at farewell
speeches and tributes for outgoing
members of Congress and the White House
starting at 12:30 p.m. Eastern with
Senator Barbara Mikulski of Maryland and
at 2:00 p.m. tributes and speeches for
Vice President Joe Biden then at 8:00
p.m. Christmas at the White House join
first lady Michelle Obama as she
receives the official White House
Christmas tree tour the White House and
seed this year's decorations make
Christmas crafting projects with
children of military families visiting
the White House and finally the tree
lighting ceremony on the National Mall
at 8:40 p.m. hear from former House
Speaker John Boehner on the Trump
presidency and his time in the Congress
and at 9:40 p.m. attend the portrait
unveiling of outgoing Senate Minority
Leader Harry Reid Democrat of Nevada
speakers include Hillary Clinton Vice
President Joe Biden and Charles Schumer
on Sunday at 12:30 p.m. Eastern we'll
hear from retiring member of Congress
representative Charles Rangel of New
York then at 2:10 p.m. from the
Shakespeare Theatre on Capitol Hill we
take you to the Romeo and Juliet
wrongful death mock trial where Supreme
Court Associate Justice Samuel Alito
serves as presiding judge and at 6:30
p.m. a look at the career of Vice
president-elect Mike Pence and his new
role as vice president watch on c-span
and c-span org and listen on the free
c-span radio app
Washington journal continues segment of
open phone down phones now again you
could talk about any topic you'd like
we'll push some more news of the day out
for you folks this story at the table
from USA Today their lead story it says
that Americans are split on Obama's
legacy they have a little chart here
rating the president what was the
president's greatest achievement twenty
four percent say the affordable care act
twenty two percent say economic recovery
from the Great Recession nine percent
moral leadership what was Obama's
biggest failure Affordable Care Act
twenty seven percent
boar's in Iraq and Afghanistan fifteen
and race relations fifteen percent this
piece also says that one thing is in
agreement across partisan lines that
President Donald Trump will
significantly dismantle Obama's legacy
three quarters of Democrats call that a
bad thing three quarters of Republicans
call it a good thing that's in USA Today
Mike is on the line now for open phones
Knoxville Tennessee independent caller
hi Mike hey what's on your mind sir well
in reference to your last segment I
realized the purpose of her book she had
to focus on some issue you can't cover
everything in a book but it was a
primarily a black and white issue that
they brought up and I really it's
terrible but I think it's probably more
systemic than what we really think the
issues that are simple to address like
that and that's not say it's a simple
issue by any means but instead of
considering everything under one
umbrella it seems to be the things that
pop up in our face color is very easy to
recognize but if you go back in history
to say Africa there were tribes raiding
other tribes in Africa and taking
workers from the other tribes we've done
it here with the American Indians have
done it white races have done it so it
actually but it's more systemic than
just race it's more of a tribalism and I
heard people go back and make references
to biblical
well police but if you're going to
address the Bible maybe this all
occurred around the Tower of Babel when
we were all separated and broken up and
it wasn't just possibly a communications
issue a verbal issue maybe it was ways
of thinking the different tribes of
Israel we're different thank you for uh
thank you for calling Beverly is calling
now from Washington DC on the line for
Democrats hi Beverly
hello there how are you hi there yes I'm
a the suggestion is that I wish that
more people would would actually teach
everybody had to palm and put a lot of
them on the phones and also to build our
own homes
and make them to bill it in that way
then the society would be so much about
all especially when they have prayer in
the Holy Bible
and more people go to church on Sundays
rather than just you know go to these
bars and everything and you know the
regulator said we black people whatever
we are on problems because we do not
have one another we just were so anxious
to put the Varner's ahead of us and
getting jobs and everything and of
course they will give them mostly to
their own people you know just like that
all right get the point Beverly and
Jerry on the line from Watertown New
York Republican caller Jerry what would
you like to talk about back over the
last eight years you know President
Obama's legacy I think one of the things
that disappoints me the most is Joe
Biden before Joe became the vice
president he was represented Delaware
and kind of one of my favorite
politicians partly because he was
capable of reaching across the aisle and
coming to terms with various kinds of
things and and you know in treating
others with respect and deference he
that he never seemed to be able to
translate that into Barack Obama's
presidency he never you know was able to
have enough leverage in that presidency
to to get President Obama who at times
acted like a petulant teenager you know
he was going to do it his way Jeffrey or
Jerry what why not why do you think the
impact of the vice president was greater
well I think that part of the problem
stems from from President Obama's
personality you know he he's not the
kind of person who would would tend to
sit down and negotiate and get things
done based upon these you know look at
look at the Affordable Care Act I mean
the fact of the matter is that not a
single Republican voted for it and and
there was they took pride in that that
was as a as a citizen of the United
States I even though I think a lot of
that was good
I didn't take any pride in that because
the fact of the matter was they never
got people together and I think it Joe
Biden's senior in that chair with access
to him every day was you know didn't get
it across to him yet the only way to do
this was to you know focus ears
attentions and energies on on creating
consensus Gerry thank you for your
thoughts this morning and Rick is
calling lots of calls here about a
various topic Springfield Illinois into
pentacle or hi Rick high exec you for
taking my call you bet and my point is
about the electoral college and what I
see is a problem the implementation of
of that essentially there are a number
of states that have a winner-take-all
policy and because of that there are a
lot of people that vote differently than
what the electoral college votes in
those states are left feeling like their
vote is not being counted and I see that
on it that the daily basis on the TV in
regard to people around the United
States basically it up in arms about
Donald
being president-elect because of the
electoral college system and that's the
one thing that I think that can be
changed that would be an easy fix for
the electoral college system is to not
have a winner-take-all type system all
right Rick thanks for calling more news
from around the country and the front
page of The Denver Post here reform of
ethics codes on the table they write
that Denver city leaders are moving
closer to adopting ethics code reforms
and revamping lobbyists and gift
disclosure rules that will make it
easier for citizens to see who's wooing
officials with meals and tickets that's
in the Denver Post and in Flint Michigan
the New York Times reports the two
former Flint emergency managers are
charged over tainted water a criminal
investigation they write in to the
city's water crisis reach to the top
ranks of supervision over Flint on
Tuesday as Michigan officials announced
felony charges against two former
state-appointed emergency managers
accusing them fixating on saving money
rather than on the safety of residents
and these managers were appointed by the
governor rick Snyder to lead Flint out
of the fiscal distress were charged over
their roles in the public health crisis
and you can read more about it in the
new york times and other papers this
morning we have Jim calling from Fort
Port Royal Pennsylvania Republican
caller hi there good morning actually
I'm in honey girls Pennsylvania it's
just down the road from Port Royal got
it I like that lady head-on from Atlanta
I'm going to get that book and read it
and the saucer Anderson yeah Carol
Anderson I like like what she had to say
listen we got a problem right now we
just found out that one of the new
tactics so I don't know how new it is
been going on for a year I guess of the
terrorists okay is to hijack a truck a
18-wheeler and that's right in my
wheelhouse because that's what I do
that's what my son does and now they're
they jump in the cab they murder to
murder the driver take the truck and
then run over a bunch of people and if
anything you've got
our senators are listening to c-span
this morning how about connecting the
dots I got a license to carry here in
Pennsylvania so when I'm driving my rig
across Pennsylvania I can protect myself
but as soon as I go into New Jersey or
if I know I got a load going down in New
Jersey New York Massachusetts Maryland I
can't take my I can't take my piece with
me because I get into New Jersey and
happened to get picked up I'm going to
most probably spend a couple nights in
jail it's going to cost me about 10
grand to fight that thing so right now
what they ought to do is make an
emergency measure and let us truck
drivers carry if we have a license to
carry in the state where we reside and
we ought to be able to to cross lines
and take that protection into other
states be great Jim thank you for your
thoughts this morning Washington Post as
a story that speaks to this being talked
about a lot and the piece says that
Islamic states goal is to use fear to
drive a wedge between Muslims and others
but they do point out that Islamic state
officials in recent months have urged
the porter's to carry out attacks in
Germany by any means including using
non-traditional weapons like trucks with
the main aim of creating an anti-muslim
backlash in Europe's biggest democracy
the resulting crackdown would benefit
the Islamic state the group argues by
dividing wavering Muslims into the
jihadist corner the AP this morning also
tells us that investigators are now
looking for a Tunisian and the Berlin
market truck attack in Germany this
Tunisian man had documents found in the
truck that plowed into this Christmas
market in Berlin Germany kidnap killing
12 people and injuring 48 others and
Shelby is calling that from Tennessee or
Tallahassee Florida I'm sorry
Tallahassee Democratic caller hi Shelby
yes good morning to Brian and the vision
and mission of c-span we had a fabulous
year with feast bandwidth History
Channel and book TV I wanted to speak
and I really appreciate the interception
of the
conversation this morning with education
and with professor Anderson history and
charted chronological reviews dreams and
aspirations of the Smithsonian's new
National Museum of african-american
history and culture in our capital that
I just came back from visiting with my
husband is really a triumphant opening
and showing of the extraordinary
intersection of our of our history I
think that sometimes we get so caught up
into the division rather than
highlighting the actual progress we are
as a nation on the cup right now it
seems of a future growth we have been
building a nation out of the the pains
and struggles of not just of people but
also of of history and so I'm delighted
that we have CSUN to be able to give us
that intersected history now that
gentleman that was on with the Alliance
for Federation of children
Kevin Chavis yes it's a gentleman that
was on to create a calculation
discussion about education
most of our black children in America
are educated 99.9% are educated in
public schools public schools are funded
by property taxes throughout this nation
not by general funding not out of the
federal government funding but rather
out of property taxes and so property
taxes therefore are not private money
now when I was growing up and I'm almost
60 I always understood and my family
always understood and had me understand
that the private schools where we had in
our town were Catholic schools primarily
and then some Christian schools
we would have to pay not that we would
ask our property taxes to be diverted so
therefore there seems to be some kind of
scheme that has gone on now with a
conversion of saying that we're going to
use and they're using your in Florida an
opportunity scholarships diverting the
sales taxes that corporations are
supposed to pay to the state general
fund and the in Florida Education
Association is now in the fight of that
suit - and this Alliance man that you
had on she's a part of the folks who are
trying to get us to drop the suit
because most state constitutions in this
country state constitutions require a
public quality education to be funded
through those property taxes which is
the base of that funding all right
Shelby thank you very much for calling
Kevin Chavis American Federation for
children was on the show you can watch
his full segment at c-span org again
just type in his name in that little box
that shows up in front of you in
addition to Carol Anderson who wrote the
book white rage we have Charles from
Uniontown PA on the line now Republican
Charles what would you like to say this
morning yes sir I want to thank you for
letting me on here today hmm and I'm
just calling to just to let the country
know that I was a Democrat my whole life
and I just turned Republican July
believing because I believe in President
Trump that he's going to make the best
president we ever had and I was in
government for years myself and for me
to turn my politics last minute in my
life so I'm retired from General Motors
for me to turn my politics
I think it's same song that's what our
head say sir thanks for calling Charles
Alfonso Brownsville Texas is calling now
on the democratic line your thoughts
Alfonso yes thank God for your program
because it's the best thing that's ever
happened on television I like to talk
about the college delegates my own
things working for us we got two bad
presidents bush and now Trump is not
working first we should get rid of it
and I think miss McHale each of each
life or pries per instruction of the
government because he has promised to
make the president a one-term president
and he has never worked with him and I
think it should be as charges treason
all right let's hear from Martin now in
Biloxi Mississippi independent color
Martin thanks for waiting your thoughts
yes I like to talk about the voter ID
I'm a veteran down here in Mississippi
and it is hard to get a voter ID voter
ID than it is to get a passport and they
they got the voter in place where you go
and get the voter ID way out about five
miles out of town so Joe citizen cannot
cannot go up there and get someone to
take him out there don't have no
questions no public transportation go
out there you go out there you got one
thing wrong then they send you back you
got to go back and and get your you
contract for you for your housing in
order and then a lot of poor people just
catching the spot they're not they're
not rent much so a contract per service
and when I went out there you almost had
to put me enforcement because I wanted
to do something to to those people out
there because I'm being a veteran they
don't recognize your gesture and ID okay
Martin thanks for sharing your situation
we'll get to a couple more your calls
but it's another big day in North
Carolina Washington Times and other
papers dealing with the special session
that the legislators have in the General
Assembly Washington
times headline says deal in repealing
the bathroom bill angers the GOP in
North Carolina North Carolina
Republicans they right have a deal for
the City of Charlotte we'll pull our
bathroom law if you pull yours so
lawmakers are prepared to repeal HB 2
the law regulating intimate public
facilities on the basis of biological
sex after the City Council in Charlotte
Monday got rid of its ordinance
requiring that access to restrooms and
locker rooms be determined based on a
person's gender identity this general
session of the Assembly will hold
another special event meeting today to
consider scrapping the law which
prompted a backlash from gay and
transgender activists and their
corporate allies including PayPal and
the National Basketball Association so
we'll be tracking the action down there
in North Carolina through the day and
through the week special session
continuing today Madeline rigidly West
Virginia Republican hi there hi I enjoy
your pub an immense right thank you like
this compliment what in the world is
wrong with the people in this country
that they can't not accept this election
whether they like Trump would think
though at least give the man a chance to
prove that the other times they can vote
him out of office I do not understand
people that claim they know God and they
would put our countries in the peril bed
in and as far as those restrooms they
need restrooms for the transgender
people not make everybody use the same
bathroom unless it's blocked and one
person at a time let's hear from Eddie
now Eddie's in Rockwell North Carolina
Democrat hi Eddie hey are you doing this
morning doing fine
because I'm on disabled Vietnam veteran
and I was just want to say how can a man
be president that won't turn in his
taxes or tax results
what do you spent the rest of the
Americans to do what do they have to
file their taxes or turn in their
results and another thing this man ain't
never done nothing by America nothing
it's always been for him and I don't
understand why the people should have to
vote either stand in lines mr. day's
work to vote when it all boils down to
570 wealthy people are people that
Cecilia tea with politics I don't make
sense why should everybody vote when it
goes down to 570 people thanks for
calling at a couple key dates January
3rd is when Congress comes back in the
house of the Senate that includes the
vote for speaker Paul Ryan up for
reelection again and January 20th of
course is the Presidential Inaugural you
can watch all of that live here on
c-span Senate's on c-span 2 and Aldrich
Nebraska now Republican caller it is
Wayne go ahead Wayne yeah Democrats get
rid of super-delegates they wouldn't be
about electoral college could Bernie
will beat Hillary bulbs anything else
from you alright thank you for calling
Casey hadn't heard the president made a
move yesterday that prohibits offshore
oil drilling in most US Arctic waters
and Atlantic waters this is the write-up
at the Alaska Daily News President Obama
ordered the closure Tuesday of 125
million acres of the Arctic Ocean and
it's estimated 27 billion barrels of oil
indefinitely the executive action bars
new leases in a vast majority of the
Arctic waters of course the Atlantic was
announced here as well but in Alaska
congressman Don Young had some language
livid language they were they right in
his response hell-bent on
knocking away our resources and
suffocating our already weakened economy
President Obama is one step closer to
solidifying his place next to Jimmy
Carter as Alaska's worst nightmare
that's at ad and calm
Kenny is calling Kenny's in Lufkin Texas
Democrat good morning morning I voted
for Hillary mm-hmm but I'm not upset
that Donald Trump won the election why
you know very optimistic about our
country have always been optimistic and
I hope things go right if people were
unsatisfied with Obama they were weren't
you know happy with the job situation I
hope that the Trop election will change
that I want Donald Trump to be
successful if he's successful our
country is successful Kenny what are you
looking what are you looking for
specifically from the next president the
new president and then Congress for that
matter I am NOT looking for anything
specific the president is he does not
create jobs and there's nothing Pacific
that I'm looking for
I just want our country to go forward
and if that's something that I'm looking
for then that's what it is I want our
country to be successful and to go
forward I felt the same way when a
Ronald Reagan was president my parents
and them did not like Ronald Reagan but
it didn't bother me that Ronald Reagan
was the president so not my other main
that Donald Trump is the president even
though I voted for Hillary Clinton now
the Republican point will have to do the
heavy lifting
all right in this current thank you Dave
or Kenny this is Dave now in Irvine
California Democratic caller what's on
your mind if okay I just want to make a
statement
real quick I hope you don't cut me off
I'll try not to okay first of all it's a
sad day in the White House since we got
a racist in there now things won't get
better with Donald Trump they'll get
worse you wait and see number two the
reason Hillary Clinton and she didn't
win is because she was against guns and
people out here won a key
their guns that's and she didn't take
Bernie Sanders said she would it took
Bernie Sanders and instead of that Tim
McCain she shoulda paid him did
everything she could she would have won
that won it hands down people want their
guns I know a lot of people that were
afraid she was going to take away all
the guns they keep talking about guns
people need their guns I'm a veteran I
was in the service you better arm up
because it gets bad out there so I don't
know you know I enjoy your show I listen
to it all the time but it's a sad day in
America when you put a racist in a White
House and he's he doesn't want to raise
the minimum wage and let's get rid of it
he's a billionaire he doesn't care about
the middle class or poor people he only
cares about the rich you wait and see
thanks it's going to get bad all right
one last call from Elaine Lakeland
Florida Republican Elaine you get the
last word this morning thank you for
professor Anderson but most of our
people let's see all people are in
denial and they're using excuses voter
registration doesn't just stop because
during the election that's a year-round
thing our voter it's not a seasonal job
it's year-round so it's time to get
started now another thing too we also
talked about